عمليات امنيه مستمره في الاردن بعد ايام
على مقتل نائب مدير شرطه محافظه معان
العميد عبد الرزاق الدبيح ثلاثه من عناصر
الامن قتلوا وجرح خمسه اخرون خلال مداهمه
استهدفت مشتبها به في مقتل العميد
الدلابيح وهم نقيب وملازم عريف بحسب ما
اعلنت مديريه الامن العام الاردنيه الامن
الاردني اضاف ان المداهمه في معان الواقعه
على بعد 218 كيلومترا جنوب العاصمه عمان
ادت الى مقتل المجتبه به وهو من حمله
الفكر التكفيري كما تم ضبط ثمانيه اشخاص
اخرين مشيره الى ان التحقيقات لا زالت
جاريه
ودانا ملك الملك عبد الله الثاني حينها
مقتل العميل متعهدا بان ينال المجرم عقابه
امام العداله على جريمه النكره بينما اصدر
وجهه وابناء معان بيانا الجمعه نعوا فيه
العميل دلابيح مؤكدين رفظهم واستنكارهم اي
فعل خارج عن القانون فيما لا يزال الالم
اعتسروا قلب الوالده والده العميد التي
دعت في لقاء سابق مع العربيه الى محاسبتي
لابنها
ربي ربي من فوق ياخذ جزائيه ومن كل اهله
ومن كل الاربانه ومن كل استني
شقيقه العميد عبد الرزاق ذبيح قال للعربيه
ان عائله العقيد تثق بالاجهزه الامنيه
الاردنيه وتقف مع الدوله مشيرا الى ان
الاجهزه الامنيه اوففت بوعدها واقتصاد من
قاتل لبنان
مع الوطن مع الاجهزه الامنيه واصدنا بيان
امبارح اعطينا الاجهزه الامنيه المده
الكافيه من اجل انه اظهار الحق واظهار
القتله القاتل بين ومعلومات اوليه الحمد
لله رب العالمين تم تصفيته
حسب معلومات اللي يعني قراناه وسمعناها من
الناس اللي شروا افضالكم اللي يعني تواصل
قالوا كان امبارح في مداهمه
للموقع اللي تم منه اطلاق النار على
المرحوم
لي
لاستثاث هؤلاء القتله الجنى